[Music]
on 20th of October 2011 Libyan leader
muar Gaddafi was captured and killed and
I tell you he was not executed in a very
civilized manner whether he deserved it
or not I'll leave that up to you to
decide the fact is that Gaddafi's death
marked the end of almost 42 years of
iron rule in 2011 Libya changed probably
forever the problem is that that change
did not exactly leave a promising
situation and since then everything has
gone from bad to worse Libya's stability
at greater risk after deadly militia
clashes turmoil in Niger and Sudan un
says Libyan flood survivors face trauma
at least 4,000 people reportedly died
when the storm hit DNA after Libya flood
unexploded weapons pose new risk during
the first week of September storm Daniel
passed through the Mediterranean causing
immense flooding in Libya the death toll
was in the thousands of course this is
only the latest of the catastrophes and
calamities that libyans have been
enduring in recent years the fall of the
Gaddafi regime led to a second Civil War
and immense chaos but what exactly
happened after the fall of Gaddafi why
did Libya end up in the deepest chaos
and will the country be able to recover
in the coming years well engines on and
let's get
[Applause]
[Music]
started visual politic viewers sometimes
history can be much more repetitive than
we can imagine as illustrated by this
prime example on the 4th of May 1980
ysep Bros Tito the Undisputed leader of
the once great Yugoslavia passed away
his death triggered a host of ethnic and
political tensions in the Balkans which
ended badly Tito's disappearance brought
with it the disintegration of Yugoslavia
and a host of conflicts and bloody wars
but wait a minute wasn't this supposed
to be a video about Libya well yes it is
we're not out of our minds not yet the
point is is that the overthrow and
assassination of Gaddafi Lord and Master
of contemporary Libya gave way to a very
similar scenario you see Libya is a
complex country it is socially composed
of multiple factions of different tribes
and ethnicities we're talking about more
than 30 tribes and family Clans that
historically have had a lot of influence
in the politics of this country over the
last five decades what all these groups
had in common was on the one hand the
Iron Fist system that ruled the country
and on the other hand the huge apparatus
of favors Privileges and oil populism
led by Gaddafi you know the good old
carrot and stick
policy but when Gaddafi fell all that
kind of stability and Harmony paid for
with oil money disappeared no transition
took place so the country plunged into
complete chaos and that can be explained
by this the tribes and sects that make
up these more artificial states have
long been held together by the Iron Fist
of colonial Powers Kings or military
dictators they have no real citizens in
the modern sense Democratic rotations
and power are impossible because each
tribe lives by the motto rule or die
either my tribe or sect is in power or
we're dead Thomas L fredman American
writer three-time politzer Prize winner
but what exactly happened after the fall
of the regime of the great leader of
Arab socialism well we are about to find
out from successful takeoff to crash
landing in 2011 the Arab Spring broke
out in Tunisia a process of political
protest that quickly spread throughout
North Africa and parts of the Middle
East Libya was no exception suddenly
large demonstrations and protests
against the government were Unleashed a
movement that ended up turning into a
real Civil War on the 26th of February
2011 the United Nations security Council
approved freezing the assets of Libyan
government leaders and also declared an
arms embargo on the country later on the
17th of March it also approved the
establishment of a no fly zone
supposedly to protect civilians in Rebel
areas from air strikes from the Libyan
Armed Forces these two resolutions were
pushed by France and the United Kingdom
but neither Russia nor China vetoed the
initiative in other words the whole
world turned against Gaddafi and in fact
shortly afterwards it was NATO itself
that intervened in this conflict to
annihilate the military capabilities of
the Tripoli regime in the end as we've
already told you the regime fell and in
October of that same year Gaddafi
himself ended up being captured tortured
and executed Libya came to be led by the
so-called National transitional Council
this body was in control for 10 months
its mission was clear to stabilize the
country and organize elections that
would usher in a new Democratic phase
Libya is an independent Democratic State
wherein the people are the source of
powers the city of trpi shall be the
capital of the state Islam is the
religion of the state and the principal
source of legislation is Islamic jurist
Prudence Sharia the state shall
guarantee for non-muslims the freedom of
practicing religious rituals Arabic is
its official language the state shall
guarantee the cultural rights of all
components of Libyan society and its
languages shall be deemed National ones
constitutional Declaration of the
national transitional Council the
country complied and in July 2012
elections were held to choose the
National Congress which would then be
tasked with electing a prime minister
and launching a constituent process in
those elections 61.5% of libyans
eligible to vote took part at that time
everything looked great the Outlook was
reasonably promising yes there was a lot
of tension but in less than a year the
country had been able to organize a
national election and former government
nevertheless the optimism lasted about
as long as an ice cream in the
[Music]
desert in Libya's 2012 parliamentary
elections a system known as the single
non-transferable vote was used this
means that voters had a single vote that
they could cast for an individual
candidate in their districts that's all
no National candidates which led to the
widespread election of independent
profiles the problem is that this split
the Congress into multiple monoblocks
limiting the possibility of creating and
sustaining stable majorities to make
matters worse all sorts of radical
islamist factions such as Isis began to
proliferate and saw the opportunity to
take advantage of the misrule to gain
territory nevertheless fresh elections
were held in 2014 but in those elections
the turnout was only 18% and shortly
thereafter everything broke down a
faction of the former members of the
National Congress refused to recognize
the results and established a parallel
government in Tripoli it was the
so-called government of national
salvation at the same time the newly
elected Congress formed their own
government in to Brook a Libyan City
that borders
Egypt of course the existence of two
parallel governments was the final straw
the division spread to the armed forces
and the country was plunged into a
second Civil War and visual politic
Community if we add to the internal
struggle among libyans the rise of the
Islamic State the formation of
autonomous local militias such as the
tur and the tubu and the proliferation
of Syrian Russian Egyptian and Turk
interests Libya ended up becoming the
kind of place where everyone was against
each other by 2015 as you could see the
map of this country was the board of one
of those puzzles that nobody knows how
on Earth to put together a puzzle
composed of different governments tribes
and jihadist groups in short the
existence of a United Libya seemed a
thing of the past and not surprisingly
all these clashes also had consequences
for the biggest business in this country
good old black
gold
Libya has one of the 10 largest
conventional oil reserves in the world
and until the Arab Spring broke out its
production level was growing
progressively however since then
everything has changed as you can see
production plunged 75% in 2014 2015 and
2016 and although it has since recovered
it is still 30% below its 2010 levels I
had more faith in the Europeans given
Libya's proximity being invested in the
follow-up the degree of tribal division
in Libya was greater than our analysts
had expected and our ability to have any
kind of structure there that we could
interact with and start training and
start providing resources broke down
very quickly Barack Obama in any case in
December 2015 the Libyan political
agreement was signed an agreement
promoted by the United Nation Security
Council that established dialogue
between the various political factions
in the country this served to set in
motion a peace process and finally in
2020 most of the Waring sides managed to
agree on a ceasefire and establish an an
electoral agenda the new government is
composed of a presidential Council led
to date by Muhammad meni and a prime
minister Abdul Hamed the baby both have
been in office since February and March
2021 respectively their mission was to
prepare the ground to organize fresh
elections something they have not yet
done so the question is why haven't
elections been held what is the
situation in Libya today who is running
the show well pay attention because the
future may not look so different from
the
past
a new
leader the second Civil War produced a
host of leaders including several
civilians such as ARF alied former
Libyan ambassador to the United Arab
Emirates and Abdul Hamed debe the
current prime minister however the
heavyweights for the time being remain
focused on names that refer to the past
and not to the Future for example we can
find a certain sa Al Islam Gaddafi does
the last name ringer Bell exactly it's
none other than the son of muar Gaddafi
who in November 2021 announced his
intention to participate in the
presidential elections the Libyan
dictator's firstborn son has been since
the overthrow of his father a kind of
puzzle piece in the negotiations between
the various factions vying for control
of the
country you see sa Al Islam Gaddafi was
left in the hands of the zintan militia
which operated in the northwest of Libya
and which somehow had no fixed side in
the second Civil War in any case the
Libyan House of Representatives
considered granting him an amnesty as
part of the peace process but the rest
of Libya's political actors rejected
this option even so he was ultimately
released in 2017 and his whereabouts
have been a mystery ever since he
appeared in 2021 in a Southern Libyan
City to announce his candidacy for the
presidency despite the fact that he is
under a death sentence imposed by courts
in Tripoli and has an arrest warrant
issued by the international criminal
court itself but such is the state of
Libya
today then at the opposite end of the
spectrum we have Khalifa belim haa Alani
an old acquaintance in Libyan
[Music]
politics an army colonel he was
imprisoned and sent into Exile by
Gaddafi himself after having a bad
outcome against chadian Rebel factions
during a border conflict in the 1980s of
course in 2011 hater saw his chance and
returned to the country as a flambo an
warlord in 2014 when the second civil
war broke out he led the Libyan National
Army under the authority of the elected
House of Representatives who was not
recognized by the government in Tripoli
haa is an outspoken critic against the
current national Accord government
Khalifa haar The Libyan warlord is not
interested in reaching a compromise
famously cantankerous the 76-year-old
warlord does not appear interested in
reaching a deal he launched an offensive
to capture trapo in April hours after un
Secretary General Antonio gutterz landed
in the capital to prepare for a peace
conference hater's troops were oblivious
to the peace process until they were
forced to lay down their arms after the
national ceasefire of 2020 despite this
he does not seem particularly committed
to any democratic transition and many
see him as one of the major obstacles in
that path however it's not all bad news
since March 2023 a mechanism called 6
plus 6 has been in operation where six
members of the Libyan House of
Representatives and six members of the
government's High Council of State
negotiate the bases and conditions for
holding elections Saif al- Islam
Gaddafi's candidacy is for the time
being annulled since the electoral
process is not open to the participation
of individuals convicted by the courts
and even haftar in spite of everything
seems to have been persuaded un Envoy
haar agree on need to finalize draft
electoral laws I met with field Marshall
Khalifa haar today in Benghazi we agreed
on the need to final ize the draft
electoral laws by the 6 plus6 committee
and create conducive conditions for
inclusive national elections in Libya
abdulle bailly un Envoy to Libya and
that's how things stood when a new
disaster came along which has changed
things once
again taking
[Music]
advantage during the first weeks of
September 2023 storm Daniel caused real
deuses in country bordering the
Mediterranean in Libya this phenomenon
caused dams to collapse and rivers to
overflow to give you an idea in places
like albaa in the northeast of the
country the equivalent of 18 months of
normal rainfall fell in just 24 hours
the floods Left Behind thousands and
thousands of dead and missing people and
tens of thousands of victims in a
country where it seems that no sooner
does it get out of one disaster that it
gets into another worse one of course
where many saw a tragedy others found an
opportunity Khalifa haftar took
advantage of the occasion to present
himself as the manager of the rescue of
the people Khalifa haftar will use
Libya's floods to deepen his control
East Libya strongman keeps tight control
over Aid after floods the disaster that
struck DNA on 11 September has drawn
renewed International attention to Mr
haar and his so-called Libyan National
Army a military Coalition that controls
the eastern half of the divided North
African nation with an iron fist these
days the territories controlled by this
warlord function as true military
dictatorships nothing escapes his
control perhaps for this reason
governments such as meone in Italy see
haftar as someone capable of stabilizing
migration issues in the Mediterranean
despite the fact that he is considered a
leader not that aligned with the west
and do you know what this is where
Moscow also comes in the Kremlin is
following the Libyan situation very
closely for one very specific reason
gas Libya is it turns out not only has
oil it also has gas in fact it is among
the 20th largest natural gas reserves in
the world yet gas exports have not been
able to recover to even 50% of preg
Gaddafi overthrow levels therefore a new
stable Libya Allied to Brussels would
represent a new energy partner to help
meet European gas demand this of course
is of no interest to Vladimir Putin's
Russia this is what motivates Russia to
back halfar while the US and several
European nations sustain through the UN
support for the government of national
Accord and its quest for elections East
Libya strongman haftar meets Putin in
Moscow of course you know that politics
is politics so contacts are already
taking place between Washington and
hafta to avoid any nasty surprises in
the short term and in fact in the past
Khalifa haftar himself worked with the
CIA to the point of obtaining US
citizenship now this old warlord seems
to be saying that he might compromise on
the elections if he can Ensure that one
of his sons could run family politics a
classic visual politic Community the
last 12 years have been very hard for
libyans from all that Arab Spring full
of democratic idealism little or nothing
remains today the failure of the
transition plan and the growing role of
a military warlord who promises order
and exchange for Freedom does not bode
well for the country's future well stay
tuned but for now it's your turn was The
Cure worse than the disease for the
libyans do you think they would have fed
better under Gaddafi what future do you
see for this country leave us your
answers in the comments and now if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like And subscribe to visual
politic if you haven't already done so
all the best see you next
[Music]
time